my name is kelsey zapata and i am a team
member at zapata's cleaning services
today we will be showing you how we deep
clean a kitchen especially the areas
that are commonly missed a lot of places
that are missed are places that are just
not seen
so for example you don't see behind your
refrigerator you don't see behind your
oven you don't see where your hood
filter goes it's something that's
commonly missed and if items like these
are not cleaned properly they're not
going to last very long and you're going
to get a lot of dirt debris and buildup
most kitchens will have the filters
they're always going to be above the
stove this was a outdoor hood vent
filter
so i think maybe it being outside made
it much more worse because of the
weather
so once we have our gloves on we take
all the pieces down carefully and then
we spray it down with our favorite
degreaser which is dawn power wash
the worse the buildup the more i'll let
it soak so these we let it soak for
about a good 30 minutes
we turned the hot water on let it run
for a few seconds and then we rinsed it
all off
one of their jobs is to capture the
grease while you're cooking and that
grease can build up and turn into thick
layers of grease and that's why you want
to clean them regularly at least once a
month maybe even more if you cook a lot
so that all that grease can get cut down
and the filter can can continue to do
its job properly
we had to get like a scrub brush to kind
of get some of the pieces but for the
most part the dawn was able to lift all
of that
this is an older looking one they all
look differently but they all do the
same job their job is to circulate the
air and catch the grease which is why
you see those brown marks that's all
grease
build up
so your filter should not look like that
if it does look like that you need to
clean it
and it's important to remember that not
cleaning those hood filters is also a
smoke hazard because that steam and
smoke is going to stay in that filter
down here in georgia we deal with a lot
of hard water so a lot of that build up
besides the grease that you see a lot of
those white marks are just a hard water
buildup
we put our gloves on we did not want to
touch anything in there and we put our
mask on because the smell was very
foul we pulled out all the filter pieces
we did soak it in hot water and vinegar
to try to loosen as much of that food
debris off
so vinegar is acidic so it will eat away
at things it's a really good natural
cleaner
it worked but there was still stuff
caked on there we went in with the dawn
power wash let it sit for about 20
minutes and then it looked brand new
afterwards
then we tackled the dishwasher i poured
vinegar all on the bottom of the
dishwasher to mask the smell they were
there for six months there was food just
just food pieces of chicken that were
just stuck in the inside of it so
there's no way that they were rinsing
the dishes then when i realized how
thick the grease was
we had to bring out our dupray steamer
and once we brought our steamer out it
made the cleaning so quick and easy
the grease was lifting
the hard water marks were lifting the
steamer will sanitize
degrease
and disinfect all with water
so once everything was clean to an
extent we put all the filter pieces back
we locked them into place we put the
racks back in and then we got in a fresh
dishwashing tablet and we put it where
the detergent pods go in and then we ran
a normal high heat cycle
so with a normal dishwasher first thing
we do is we always take out the filter
scrub it with some hot water and some
vinegar to get any food debris off rinse
it with water put it back into place
and then i'll get some vinegar and spray
like the harder to reach areas like
where the sealant part is i'll spray
that with vinegar scrub it with a grout
brush and i'll put everything back and
i'll use a fresh tablet or if i don't
have those on me that day i will pour
some vinegar into a dishwasher safe cup
put it on the top rack and run a hot
normal cycle the vinegar will lift any
soap scum grime or like any other sticky
residue
so after your vinegar cycle pull out the
rack take out that cup of vinegar
and then we'll pour baking soda on the
bottom of the dishwasher
close it back up and run another hot
normal cycle and the baking soda will
really help deodorize and take out any
weird smells in there it's important to
use these two products separately you
don't want to use them together because
if you use them together they turn into
salt
you want to clean this appliance at
least once a month this is because a
dirty filter
is not going to get your dishes clean
you're going to come across lots of dust
and just whatever has slid under your
fridge and also if you have pets there's
going to be a lot of pet hair back there
too
after we safely move the refrigerator
you don't want to yank it you don't want
to pull it because it is going to be
connected with a wire just kind of check
the area make sure there's no loose
wires before you just start vacuuming
and we start vacuuming the baseboard the
wall the coils to get all that dirt and
dust off
we use a foaming action spray
we used a microfiber cloth because
that's really good at trapping dust and
dirt
you want to at least pull that out
two to three times a year if you have a
bigger family and you have a lot of pets
you probably want to do it more
but at least a minimum of three times a
year
cleaning the inside of an oven is
probably the last thing you want to do
after cleaning your whole kitchen so the
more you let the oven go the worse it's
going to get so that's just cooking oils
and food splatter so first thing we do
is pull out the racks
and we will spray the racks down with
the blue easy off
and the reason that we use the blue can
of easy off is because that is
an oven cleaner that is safe
for self-cleaning ovens once we spray
the racks we then go back to the oven
and we will check out the bottom of the
oven and if there's any loose or burned
food debris
we will wipe all that out with paper
towels try to get as much of that loose
food debris off the bottom of the oven
and then we go in with the easy off and
just spray a generous amount of product
and then we close the door and let it
sit a minimum of 1 hour and 15 minutes
depending on how bad the buildup is
we go in with sos pads and scrub and
scrub and scrub until everything comes
off they are a type of steel wool
abrasive pads and they are the thickest
grits that you can use
we'll wipe that first layer of product
off with paper towels to get as much of
it off as possible and then the key is
to rinse with water so we'll spray water
we'll wipe we'll wipe again and we'll
wipe again because one common um
question we get with this product is
i've used it but it leaves a white
residue well that's because you didn't
rinse you're going to want to rinse your
oven at least four or five times to
ensure that all that product is taken
off and nothing stays behind
about once a month give it a deep
cleaning we do not encourage the
self-clean oven cycle there is way too
many risk and fire hazards with that
you know when you cook on your stovetop
grease and food's going to splatter and
it can fall on the sides of the oven in
this particular instance we used a scour
daddy which is scour daddy is really
good at at lifting thick grease caked on
grease we use the spray away cleaner too
because it has that foaming action that
can really like lift all that build up
and then we just kind of went back over
it to make sure everything was taken off
bugs will definitely get drawn in there
especially if there's food that gets
stuck in there
so when you pull it out you might see
some dead bugs stuck in there and if
you're ever wondering if there's like a
foul odor in your kitchen pull out your
oven there might be some stuff that's
gotten behind the oven and on the sides
of the oven